[Musik]
mein name ist kooperativ gomez beim
panzergrenadierbataillon 13 in der
kaderpräsentation hat in meiner
derzeitigen funktion bericht schütze und
schützenpanzer ulan
ich habe schon gefragt ob da sie zum
bundesheer gehe und mir dann im internet
und in den medien einfach genau
informiert über die
kaderpräsenzeinheiten und danke sagen
dass es das richtige ist für mich
ja es gibt eigene überprüfungen dies
medizinisch psychisch und körperlich
nachdem ich im vorhinein genau wusste
was mir da wirklich im endeffekt nur
körperlich darauf vorbereitet china
das hast du für ausdauer und kraftsport
grundgehalt ist einmal 1400 euro netto
das kann man noch überstunden dazu
zählen auch übungs wir haben sehr
verschieden wir waren zum beispiel vier
wochen einen neuen stall und das sondern
in etwa 1800 euro netto und im ausland
kann man mit 3000 euro netto im monat
rechnen grundsätzlich ja sehr hohe
planungssicherheit aber seinen urlaub
betrifft spricht 2013 habe bereits im
frühjahr einen urlaub gewährt und vom
dienstherr wissen eigentlich einmal wie
lange dienstag nur es kann nicht sein
dass mal alarmiert wird bzw
also man ins ausland muss und das ganze
sehr kurzfristig wir haben zweiten dort
bereits alarmierung für den kosovo
gehabt und das war schon die größte
überraschung in meiner bisherigen
dienstzeit
im ausland haben wir vor allem die es
anwenden kinder was man gelernt haben
und was mir persönlich sehr interessiert
hat war die zusammenarbeit mit andere
armeen und einer sektor von dem
jeweiligen land in dem man groß
stationiert ist also der grund
verpflichtungszeit von beträgt einmal
drei war
man kann das ganze mal bis zu sechs jahr
verlängern und es wird berufsförderung
im nachhinein angeboten
das ganze wird man vom heer finanziert
wenn sie die berufsförderung außer man
während der dienstzeit machen ob sie das
gehalt der kurskosten bekommen sie
ersetzt ist dass er dort nicht mehr
aktiven dienst dann bekommt er von uns
75 prozent seines letzten bruttogehaltes
als unterstützung und man kann so
ausbildung auch im ausland in anspruch
nehmen wenn diese ausbildung in
österreich nicht angeboten wird
ich persönlich mag zum beispiel meine
matura noch um den trainingskurs und es
gibt dann auch so etwas wie eine besten
auswahl dass man zum beispiel auf
unteroffizier seine offizierslaufbahn
kurs gehen kann